so you could let them come in please
great job great thank you for the tour
that's uh something they love seeing you
yeah no
it's it was a great honor if you feel
more comfortable you'll say a couple of
words you might want to take the mask
off otherwise you can leave them on
either way you want look how fast you
took that off
well thank you very much everybody for
being here we
took a really incredible tour and law
enforcement has just done
such a great job working with the
national guard and
working with a lot of people but we're
here to show our support
for kenosha and wisconsin the state of
wisconsin has been very good to me
i love the people we've done a lot for
the state and we will continue to do a
lot for the state
we're all in this together and this was
an example of what can happen when you
do it right
i'm pleased to be joined today by
attorney general bill barr who's doing a
really a fantastic job and bill thank
you very much for being here
secretary chad wolfe chad
chad thank you ron johnson senator ron
johnson who's uh
outstanding i have to tell you so
respected within
the beautiful halls of congress and uh
i appreciate the great job you do ron i
hope the people of wisconsin appreciate
how good a senator is do they have any
idea do they know how good he is i think
they do
you're never going to get not elected
run or i'll be very unhappy
one of the best and also a young
congressman that's been a warrior
true warrior he's been a fighter not
only for
some other very good causes but for this
cause because he was the first one to
call me and say we have a problem
and brian i want to thank you brian
style congressman and
you have your first re-election and i
think you're going to win it big i hope
you do you deserve to
also my former chief of staff where's
reince
reince where is my reins reince priebus
which shows that i definitely like this
state because you are
a very proud uh citizen of right here
you're still here you never left did you
you never would leave you've done a
great job thank you very much ryan
kenosha has been ravaged by anti-police
and anti-american riots
they have been hit so hard and
we were able to get involved and david
beth
and daniel miskinus
who i've been watching a lot on
television now today i got to know him
both very well and they have done an
incredible job and you're going to say a
few words in
a couple of minutes and we would
appreciate it also
zach rodriguez supervisor kenosha county
zach thank you very much jack good job
you had a rough uh three days but then
it got well brought into
uh back in where you wanted it just
where you wanted it
that aaron decker supervisor for kenosha
aaron thank you erin good job thank you
very much
don kapla president of wisconsin
fraternal order of police
don thank you very much jerry johnson
national trustee of the wisconsin
fraternal order of police
jerry thank you people have done a
fantastic job really you have to be
proud of them
james and sharon ward pastors where is
uh
well it was great speaking to you
yesterday
and uh you're really a very respected
man and i really enjoyed our
conversation thank you both very much
for being here
appreciate it uh we also have uh
major general paul knapp who is around
here someplace but he was
really right on the right on the thank
you very much paul
thank you he's been fantastic paul and
scott and linda carpenter owners of b l
office furniture scott you're back there
someplace thank you
thank you very much uh you got hit
pretty hard right
yes you got hit p pretty hard that's all
right it's going to get rebuilt
kimberly warner owner of the authentic
gifts
and report candle factory that's a very
fancy name you have their report
that's a fancy name but i'll bet it was
beautiful is it uh are you going to
rebuild
will you be rebuilding
but we'll be giving you some help okay
we'll be giving you some help
john wrote the third owner of rhodes
camera shop now i i was
there and that was 109 years and uh
you want to say a couple of a couple of
words would you like to i'd say
where where is he oh okay
good john stand up please 109 years
thank you again for coming thank you for
sending the national guard
and again did an awesome job as well as
the
fire department kept up as business
and we're going to help you that's a
very very complete rebuild we're talking
about down there that's
incredible if they would have responded
to the first call it would have been uh
it would have been a little different
story but they did respond which is
better than some governors frankly
and uh once they responded and once we
took
you know control of it things went
really well you just met some very
talented people outside and
uh i think you're gonna have clear
sailing but we'll we're gonna try giving
you a hand
your insurance company you're insured
right yes and so they're helping and
they're being
responsible so far everything you'll let
me know
you'll let me know you've got to let me
know at the end and ricky
talapaya tra talapaetra
that's a beauty that's a good one go
ahead please
um we have two businesses in downtown
that were vandalized
we've been able to rebuild but i also
represent the downtown kenosha
incorporated organization who's leading
the rebuilding effort for downtown
and uptown it's been it's been a
struggle but our community has been
really incredible
more people have come to help than we
know what to do but right now what
we need is financial support uh loss of
business and loss of
poverty is staggering at this point
all right we'll we'll be talking to you
we're going to be helping you with law
enforcement we're going to be helping
you with some economic development get
get it back in shape get kenosha back in
shape and we'll get it back in
i think very quickly i really think so
and we'll be helped by john morrissey
city administrator of kenosha
john thank you very much john you have
your work cut out for the next little
while but you'll be fine
i think we do you're going to be in
great shape and samantha kirkman
state representative district 61.
thank you very much congratulations on
doing a really great job
thank you thank you
great job you're doing appreciate it and
van
wan guard state senator district 21
highly respected person actually thank
you very much
thank you very much great thank you so
much for your rapid response
and the fact that that you're coming to
a small
city in the united states and just
saying that that's as important as every
other city
and the fact that we did get things
under control uh this card has been
phenomenal our law enforcement people
have been working together
we usually work pretty well together in
southeastern wisconsin yeah but this
really helps and
reince has a lot to do with that too you
can tell because you're good so thank
you so much
you're in our prayer thank you and you
your reputation's a great one so
thank you very much and also this this
area is a special area we can't let that
happen to this area so we got here
quickly
and uh did the job violent mobs
demolished or damaged at least 25
businesses burned down public buildings
and threw bricks
at police offices which your police
officers won't stand for
and they didn't stand for it these are
not acts of peaceful protest but really
domestic terror my administration
coordinated with the state and local
authorities to
very very swiftly deploy the national
guard surge federal law enforcement
to kenosha and stop the violence and i
strongly support the use of the national
guard in other cities and
the same thing would be happening if we
did that you'd have the same thing
happen in portland it would happen very
quickly it would all be over very very
quickly
and i just want to thank the two of you
for acting so strongly and so bravely
and
getting it done and the coordination has
been fantastic
you still need that coordination no
matter how many people you send in
i just came from a visit of one of the
businesses that was burned down b
l furniture and the great 109 year old
camera shop which i i really respect
because that was a
had a reputation far beyond the state
even
and it's terrible to see several other
business owners uh
they're joining us and we have some in
the back also
to stop the political violence we must
also confront the
radical ideology that includes this
violence
reckless far-left politicians continue
to push
the destructive message that our nation
and our law enforcement are
oppressive or racist they'll throw out
any word
that comes to them actually we must give
far greater support to our law
enforcement
it's all about giving them additional
support these are great people
these are great great people these are
brave people they're fighting
to save people that they've never met
before in many cases
and they're incredible we must really be
thankful that we have them and we have
to help them
do their jobs we can't be threatening
them with their pensions are going to be
taken away their job's going to be taken
away everything's going to be taken away
they're going to be
living a bad life if if they utter
an incorrect word you can't do it we
have to have our law enforcement
we cherish our law enforcement we
wouldn't be here without our law
enforcement
even me i'm here today i feel so safe
and you went through hell just a few
days ago but i feel so
safe i better be safe right i better be
safe but
we're all safe and we're safe because of
law enforcement
and we honor you and i will say this
we have to condemn the dangerous
anti-police rhetoric
it's getting more and more it's very
unfair
you have some bad apples we all know
that
and those will be taken care of through
the system
and nobody's going to be easy on them
either and you have people that joke
they're under tremendous i said it
yesterday i said it last night
they're under tremendous pressure and
they may be there for 15 years and have
a spotless record and all of a sudden
they're faced with a decision
they have a quarter of a second quarter
of a second to make a decision
and if they make a wrong decision one
way or the other they're either dead
or they're in big trouble and people
have to understand that
they choke sometimes and it's a very
tough situation
right it's a very tough then people call
them bad and horrible and
they made a bad decision but if you
think of it when they have and i know
you practice this all the time where you
give people
uh literally a quarter of a second to
make a decision
and a lot of them can't make that right
decision it's a very tough thing to do
the vast and overwhelming majority of
police officers are honorable courageous
and devoted public servants they're
incredible
yet many politicians ignore their
sacrifice and ignore the
african-american hispanic american
victims
we have people there was love on the
streets
i can tell you of wisconsin when we were
coming in
there was love on the streets and so
many african-americans hispanic
americans i can see waving
pasture was so beautiful to see they
want to have
they want to have safety they want to
have safety
you look at i'm not a huge believer in
polls obviously but you look at polls
whether it's 87 percent
want to have great police they want to
have strong police they want to have
safety they're the ones that are most
affected by tragedies like you'll see
going around
when these allegations of police
wrongdoing
and when you see that they have made
allegations
they must be fully and fairly
investigated and that's what we're doing
bill barr has done a fantastic job in
that respect and
we fully understand that because you do
you do have
problems the other way but they're very
few you know the sad thing is you can do
10 000 great jobs as a
policeman or policewoman you can do
an incredible job for years
and then you have one bad apple or
something happens that's bad and that's
the nightly news for three weeks
that's all they talk about they don't
talk about the thousands and thousands
of good jobs the lives that you save
they never talk about
so i'm committed to helping kenosha
rebuild we all are
we will provide one million dollars to
the
kenosha law enforcement so that you have
some extra
money to go out and do what you have to
do you took a rough
it was a rough week to put it mildly and
you've done it incredibly well
i'm also providing nearly four million
dollars to support these small
businesses that i talked about today
that got burned up burned down
and we're going to be providing over 42
million dollars to support public safety
statewide including direct support
for law enforcement and funding for
additional prosecutors
to punish criminals and resources to
provide services
to victims of crime and that was bill
barr wanted that money
put in so that's 42 million dollars
that'll help with prosecutors and
all of the other things that are so
important to you you need that because
when you
when you grab them and then nothing
happens and they're back on the street
that doesn't work out too well
my administration is restoring public
safety we're
hiring more police surging tough one
crime federal prosecutors increasing
penalties for assaulting law enforcement
and for
dismantling antifa it doesn't they don't
want to mention the word antifa nobody
mentions that there's a bad group of
people
very very bad very dangerous group of
people
and we are doing a big number on antifa
they're bad earlier this year we
announced operation
legend to surge federal law enforcement
to high crime neighborhoods
it is a thing that has really worked out
amazingly well bill
but it's really under sort of
really understated in a sense we we've
already conducted more than 1 000
arrests in our first month in chicago we
went to chicago very recently obviously
that's been a disaster
chicago total disaster with again
radical left democrat and we just have
to straight it's all democrat
everything's democrat all of these
problems are democrat cities we don't
want to say it but
it is the top ten or democrat then you
go into the top 25 and take a look at
that
it's the same thing we cut the number of
murders in chicago last month in half
still way too many but the uh operation
legend was very very very successful now
it's just really getting going but they
cut it in half and just
at its very early stage this in sharp
contrast to those who want to slash
police funding oppose
using the national guard and want to
hire radical judges and prosecutors
who release riders looters and criminals
we have that in portland
where the prosecutors don't want to do
anything you can catch somebody doing
the worst
crime and they don't want to do anything
so we're very very
uh upset about that so we're not going
to be
cut police funding if you look at what
they want to do they want to
cut police funding we want to increase
police funding substantially
they want to end cash bail which has
been a killer for new york
if you look at what's happening in new
york they allowed thousands of people
out of jail in new york and they're
walking around and they're causing
nothing but problems who would not know
that you don't have to know anything
about policing i'm not a policeman but i
would know that if you let these people
out
many of them are going to cause
tremendous problems so they want to end
cash bail
incentivize prison closures they want to
close the prison so that
can't hold anybody reimagine public
safety
end immigration enforcement resume catch
and release at the border uh
as uh chad will tell you we've had
tremendous success on the border we're
up to over 300 miles of border wall and
we're having the best
year we've ever had in the border people
are coming in but they only come in
legally or they
for the most part they only come in
illegally the wall will be finished very
shortly it's had a
tremendous impact so and the other thing
we want to
appoint supreme court justices
and judges we'll be up to almost 300
judges by the end of the term and two
supreme court justices
and so we have a lot of things to do we
have a lot of great things to do but
it's an honor to be in your neighborhood
it's an honor to be in your great state
wisconsin
and we're here for you all the way some
people thought it would be a good thing
for me to come a bad thing i just wanted
to come
i really came today to thank law
enforcement and to just
really that what they what you've done
has been incredible it's been really
inspiring because you see it happening
all over
and it just never seems to end and it
never seems to end because
it's almost as though they don't want it
to end because you ended it really fast
and congressman i want to thank you for
the job you did you were the first call
and i want to thank you very much brian
great really great job
with that i'd like to introduce bill
barr attorney general of the united
states say a few words thank you
thank you mr president
as most of you know whenever there is an
officer-involved shooting
in our country it's reviewed by local
authorities to ensure that it was
reasonable force
and when there are questions raised
about it the federal government also the
justice department
also reviews it and uh like all
procedures and processes in our country
uh we do it under due process
and we try to reach a dispassionate
reasoned decision
based on an analysis of the situation we
do not
allow judgments to be reached because of
mob violence
we do not have mob violence in this
country make our decisions over the fate
of individuals when when their actions
are challenged
and when the shooting occurred uh
here in kenosha under the direction of
the president
we told the dod the defense department
to get ready some national guard units
in case they were
needed to help here and from several
states volunteered to supply
national guard if they were needed and
the president directed me to
assemble a group of federal law
enforcement that could be dispatched
here
which we did and staged them in chicago
and we were picking up information
that that these violent instigators
were coming to kenosha they were coming
from california
washington state a lot from chicago
and they were coming up to kenosha so we
expected matters to get
worse the violence that erupted
shortly after the shooting is simply not
a legitimate response
to a police shooting and the looting
and the arson were unacceptable and as
it progressed it became more and more
distant from the issue of racial justice
it was violence for violence sake
and once again we saw the hijacking
of a protest by a hardcore group of
of radicals uh who were carrying out
planning a coordinated violent attack on
law enforcement on public property and
on private property
and that can't be tolerated these are
the the same
people many of them who came from out of
town out of 175 arrests
100 were from out of town and some
these are the same people using the same
tactics that have been used in various
cities washington dc
atlanta chicago now kenosha
portland and they use these black block
tactics throwing projectiles at police
and literally trying to inflict injuries
on police
arson and rioting they came equipped as
even the mayor of washington
acknowledged they come equipped
to fight and uh
it's completely unacceptable and the
state
is the first line of defense and if
local leaders
are committed to keeping public safe it
can be done
and uh while it was slow in getting off
the starting block this is an example
that when you have the local political
leadership backing the police
you have the state willing to put in the
resources in terms of national guard
and the federal government able to come
up with support
such as the fbi the marshals and atf who
have some special
skills and forensic ability to help
there will be peace on the streets
and there's going to be accountability
what people don't see is that in all of
these cities
there are task forces of federal and
state officers reviewing all the video
that we can get our hands on and when we
are able to identify people who
committed crimes in these riots
going all the way back to the beginning
whether they're burning police cars
or throwing rocks at people which are
deadly
they will be prosecuted that's a
large-scale effort and it's going to
continue
so i can i can tell you mr president
that as far as
the federal government is concerned we
we
welcome the opportunity to work with
state and local
to deal with this public safety issue
law enforcement is used to
working together we do a good job when
we're allowed to work together
this is no different than dealing with
violent crime where we work together
we can achieve results and
the federal government is willing to use
all our tools and all our laws to bring
these people to justice
thank you very much you're doing a great
job bill thank you senator ron johnson
from
your wonderful state and he is one of
the great senators i can tell
you that in the u.s senate he's one of
the best
ron cliff there's no doubt
what you've been talking about in terms
of the decisiveness the resolve
the surging of resources i think 44
different counties and
representatives from different sheriff
departments that really helped
stop the rioting and and bring peace
this the streets
but we have you know pastor ward and his
wife and and i reached out because
i was just so appreciative of julie
jackson's words
of forgiveness and of healing
and so you combine the proper role of
law enforcement the support for law
enforcement
with people that also want to
end the violence that are willing to
forgive and are willing to offer those
words of healing so i thought that was
very powerful i was really appreciative
mrs ward thanks for talking to me and
then you know
pastor ward thanks for calling me back
um
that's also incredibly important here in
wisconsin
a little bit of aside but charles
krauthammer once gave a speech here he
said you always hear minnesota nice
i say wisconsin even nicer and that's
true i mean
we are nice people we have common sense
we all share the same goal we all want a
safe a prosperous but secure
kenosha wisconsin america so we really
do share the same goal so as important
and it is it's so important to support
law enforcement
and my message to the folks out here is
that it's a very small percentage of the
american population that are
that are doing the rioting that are
trying to defund the police the vast
majority
of americans are so appreciative of the
service and the sacrifice
and the help they get from law
enforcement so i'm trying i don't want
law enforcement to be dispirited at all
because the vast majority of americans
are
for you the vast majority of
wisconsinites but at the same time it
takes american citizens to offer those
words of forgiveness
and trying to attain that type of unity
and healing so
again mr president i thank you for
coming here for for coming here to thank
law enforcement to support law
enforcement
but also coming here just to support the
citizens of kenosha
and wisconsin as we rebuild as as we
recover from something that the vast
majority people
abhorred and do not support thank you
very much ron
appreciate it congressman please brian
style
mr president i appreciate you being here
as events spiraled out of control
um people started calling me they were
scared
they were nervous they were concerned
about their safety their family's safety
their home their place of employment and
they were looking for where to turn
it was very clear from talking to folks
here in the city of kenosha
local elected leaders that we needed
additional resources in the community of
kenosha
immediately that's ultimately why i
called you
on tuesday morning and after
only seven minutes you got on the phone
with me
you said brian i'm there for the people
of kenosha
and the people of kenosha everyone that
called me
wanted public safety here in this
community they wanted it
immediately they didn't care if the help
was democrat republican or from the man
on the moon
but what you did is made the call and
said enough's enough
we need to get resources into the
community of kenosha and ultimately when
that offer was accepted
i think it became very clear to the
criminal element
that they knew that kenosha meant
business
we made some significant arrests in
conjunction with local law enforcement
working very well
with the federal government hand in
glove when i talk to folks
in law enforcement here in kenosha and
when the federal government works
hand in hand with the state and with
local government you can get a lot done
and i think it speaks volumes about the
people
here in the community of kenosha this is
a hard-working
family-loving town that wants safety in
their community
and one more piece is i've had the
opportunity to talk to a lot of the men
and women in law enforcement those on
the front lines
i spoke to a gentleman that had a brick
thrown at him i've spoken to law
enforcement officers who had horrific
words said about them
and these men and women are members of
our community that wake up
every day put the badge over their heart
walk out the door
sworn to answer the call to protect
our community and i think you coming and
saying thank you
to those men and women in law
enforcement speaks volumes
and today we have public safety restored
we appreciate all the work you did on
that
and now we begin the work of healing and
rebuilding kenosha
to make kenosha stronger than it's ever
been before we thank you very much for
being here thank you brian great job
david beth sheriff please mr president
thank you so much for being here
um when this started sunday night we
knew it was going to get
worse but we really didn't know how bad
and there's no way
that one or in our case two agencies can
work together to
fight what happened when we put out the
call
initially to the state and local law
enforcement here
it was a tremendous response but it
still wasn't enough on monday night
the national guard started coming on
monday night and started helping us and
their numbers kept growing
and we called brian on tuesday morning
early the the leaders of kenosha
and we said we'll take help from whoever
will send it our way
we'll we want to protect the people of
kenosha the city of kenosha the county
of kenosha we want to protect it
and brian said i'm going to make a phone
call and a short time later
we knew that the resources of the of the
united states of the federal government
and of the president
were on its way and we we knew that it
took a little
a little uh discussion between
state and federal levels and but we're
very thankful
that it worked out because as i said i
didn't care who i got help from
i wanted resources here and after
it was approved uh and and
i got the word that the president said
whatever you need it's coming
and i had some of uh some very
very important people from washington
tell me
the president i have to report to the
president mr barr and tell him what does
the sheriff want
and and the resources just kept coming
the people kept coming
the uh the gratitude kept coming for
and i heard stories and i probably
shouldn't share this but some people
that were in portland
that weren't treated as good as they
were treated here and they said
we can't believe what a different place
this
is because of how we all worked together
rather than not wanting to work together
at all
so thank you for being the president
that likes law enforcement on behalf of
law enforcement i'm telling you
the group that's here i i hope you could
feel the love that they have for you and
everybody who came and
and uh it's quite an operation to
watch to be part of and truth to my life
my life i never thought i would see
anything like this and hopefully i never
have to see this again
but uh the resources that that uh
in this case the federal government and
you provided and mr barr
and and mr johnson and the people here
it's
unbelievable what we have here right now
and uh it's all to protect the people of
kenosha and
and uh i still i'll take any help i can
get and i thank you for it
thank you sheriff i'll tell you you've
done a great job and you know just
if they're watching portland or chicago
or
new york or any one of other cities that
we're talking about
but portland probably would be so easy
maybe that would be the first one
because i see it every night it's on the
news it's burning
they're always playing games and i don't
know then he gets up and says we're
trying to work together
the whole thing is great then they want
to burn down his house last night the
mayor
but we're ready willing and able to send
in
you know a massive group of people that
are really highly trained you saw that
they're here your experience right and
we could solve that problem in less than
an hour in portland so i hope they call
eventually they'll call
and at some point bill would just have
to do it ourselves we're gonna have to
do
something that's uh uh that i think the
people will be extremely happy with
maybe the mayor won't and maybe the
governor won't but i don't know if they
know what they're doing i just
so sad to watch it happen but here you
acted
and acted appropriately please daniel go
ahead
mr president first of all thank you for
the support thank you for coming to
what is uh small town america kenosha's
100 000 people
by national standards we're still small
but what you also have here is a
reaction to
as an attack on small town america the
tactics that are being used across this
nation
to attack law enforcement are
warfare type tactics and we still use
restraint
and function within our rules so those
two together
there's not an is not a tit for attack
those aren't equal so with the ability
of the national guard to come out and
assist us
with the tremendous outpouring of
support from the federal assets
from every department that has come out
we will
excuse me we were able to restore peace
and we're working toward
order and healing and growth and as part
of what is going on in the world
police scrutiny is not a bad thing
police are attacks on the police and the
things that are happening that lead to
riots
that's not about police scrutiny that's
not about anything else those are those
are legitimate attacks so
what worked for us was we certainly had
a unified command we had a unified
mission
that normally takes some time to build
but instantly between myself and the
sheriff and the local leaders city
administration
county we pulled together we worked with
the city we worked with state we worked
with officers
from southeast of here and there's not a
lot southeast of wisconsin or
kenosha to the northwest corner of the
state we have people from two steps away
from canada
sending officers down here so the
response here in the law enforcement
community
was tremendous and everybody i talked to
was here to help
restore peace and order for the good
people of kenosha and thank you for
helping us thank you daniel great job
you did thank you and you two work
together beautifully it's really good
really good job please chad well
thank you mr president uh americans need
and deserve both law enforcement and
public safety regardless of where they
live
regardless of their politics the
decrease in violence that we've seen
here in kenosha over the last several
days
is really just a prime example of how
federal state and local
law enforcement can work together it's
really a model
that we can replicate elsewhere portland
and other cities across the country
and this administration mr president
you've been very clear if cities need
help they need assistance
if they need resources and capabilities
beyond their reach
all they have to do is call law
enforcement the federal government and
we will be there
dhs partners not only with the
department of justice but with local
communities every day to protect
the citizens of those communities we're
providing law enforcement here in
kenosha some assistance
until you're able to rebuild and get
back on your feet so
certainly want to extend our
appreciation for what you do
and let me just say the attacks on law
enforcement recently
have been very vocal about that are very
disgusting
we need to thank our men and women of
law enforcement they put on a badge
and a uniform every day they're attacked
every day for simply wearing that
uniform and doing their job so
again on behalf of the 240 000 men and
women of the department
i want to say thank you to the local law
enforcement for doing your job
and protecting your communities thank
you really nice thank you
pastors would you like to say a prayer
yes sir i'd love to have that uh because
you are
so highly thought of in the area so
please james sharon
mr pray please father we come to you in
the name of our lord jesus christ and we
thank you
for this time that you've divinely
ordained
father we ask you to forgive us all
where we've strayed from your ways and
where we've not acknowledged your word
we ask that you would
continue to cause this nation to be one
nation
under god that you alone are the one who
can make us
individual indivisible and by being
indivisible there will
be liberty and justice for all we simply
pray that you would bring our nation
back
to you that your word will be dominant
that you would cause us uh to walk in
love to live in love restore empathy and
compassion
kindness concern for each other lord i
pray for our president
as your word says that you would
strengthen him and continue to give him
the wisdom
and the heart to lead during his time as
well as as all the leaders that are here
we give ourselves to you and we ask you
for your good hand to be upon us
in the name of jesus our lord we pray
amen
thank you very much aaron would you like
to say something
i i would um i think i'm here first of
all representing
intercessors and people that are praying
just really i think
um we need to mobilize
people of prayer to pray for this
country
and also i think it's important to have
um black people at the table
um to to help you know solve the problem
and also
um i think james and i are
our prayers that we're able to work
to really bring about a change i think
there's a lot of great change that's
been mentioned here
of how law enforcement has quickly
solved the problem of
the crime in the street but i think
there's i think
this is a good opportunity for us to
really solve the problem the nation
and um i think james and i could help
with that
it's really well put yes james mr
president if i may add
being the only pastors in the room if i
could maybe just share
a little bit from a different
perspective that i think would bring
balance
i have a great friend who is chief tony
scarpelli the
chief of police in the town where our
church is right and i talk about the
partnership between pastors and police
and i often tell tony
that if we can do our job well it will
make his his job
easier that's because there are three
types of law that govern our society
there's spiritual law moral law and
civil law
most of the conversation here today has
been about civil law but until we can
really focus on spiritual and moral law
and change the hearts of people
we'll have to continue to to build
bigger jails and bigger princes
prisons until we can bring our nation
back to the place of of
spiritual and moral law um we certainly
want to honor
julia jackson we're her pastors we're
not the pastor of the entire family but
on her you know yes sir i will give her
your regards
and we certainly pray for jacob's
continued healing and we pray for peace
but i just want to offer to you mr
president that um
jesus himself says blessed are the
peacemakers and we want to help be of
service to you and to our nation of
having these conversations
of how do we rebuild the foundations of
spirituality and morality
which gives us the context of love if
you give a righteous good moral man the
launch codes to our nuclear arsenal
everyone will be safe because he's a
good man but if you give a malicious man
who is immoral
an ink pen you have to fear for your
life i i would just want to want to say
that we're here
to be of service to you and to our
country to bring unity um
we believe that we can help to listen
with empathy and compassion to the real
pain
that that hurts black americans but we
want to be of service to you and to our
nation to do whatever we can
uh to bring true healing true peace and
to really see god's very best in our
nation we're here available we're
available
anytime you will call upon us so you
know what i think i think you're an
incredible couple i really do i think
you're an incredible couple thank you
and thank you very much for being here
yes sir really really great
beautiful uh do you have any questions
please
no it's not but yeah
no it's not it's just that we're tired
of watching every night with portland
they're on night 104 now
and we're tired of watching it because
it could be solved in an hour
and we're tired of watching a mayor that
has no clue what's going on
and people are calling our office and
people are calling washington
that live in portland and live in the
state
and they're saying please please send
help and the governor we should call the
governor
often and they say no we don't need your
help
but i say your community is burning down
they don't need our help now i don't
know if that's political i don't know
what
is going on certainly not common sense
but we could solve it just
like here we all work together we came
in the federal government the state
government the city government everybody
worked together
the senator the congressman it was like
a beautiful thing it just came
it just worked and it was done almost
instantly
people were amazed and as you probably
will have to
report maybe people are surprised
there's been
zero problem in terms of your safety our
safety
i feel so safe four four or five days
ago james we couldn't have done this
the law enforcement's been so great and
we could do this in portland so quickly
so easily it would
it would be incredible we would have
done it in seattle we were all set to go
into seattle as you know
the following day and they heard that
and they sent the police and the police
did a good job but they
the people gave up they were exhausted
they were there for a long time and they
gave up they were exhausted
uh so we're there i mean we'd love to
help
oregon we'd love to help really love to
help portland
because we could solve that problem so
easily we have the people there ready
they could be there in
less than an hour less than an hour
and it would all end and they got a
glimpse of that
in this great state they got a really
good glimpse of it it happened very
quickly
and now i mean i see it they're already
rebuilding you're already
rebuilding your stores you'll be
rebuilding your store soon
your camera shop uh
we don't want to do that but at some
point we're going to have to do it
we're going to have to do it okay
can you tell me what you would say to
the blake family i know you didn't get a
chance to talk to them but what would
you say to them in terms of the pain
they're going
through and the questions they have
about what happened
well i feel terribly for anybody that
goes through that that's why i was so
honored to meet the pastors i feel
terribly for anybody that goes through
that as you know it's under
investigation it's a big
thing happening right now i guess it's
under a local investigation i know bill
you're also participating
but it's under your local investigation
group unit and i hope they come up with
the right answer it's a complicated
subject to be honest with you
but i feel terribly for anybody that has
to go through and
i didn't get to speak to the mother
i hear she's a fine woman i've heard
that from the pastor
a really fine woman but you can see when
i spoke to the pastors i
i see exactly what it is and they
understand where i am
and if we can help we're going to help
but it is a question
it's under investigation a lot of things
happened with that
and other things frankly that we're
looking at very very closely
okay
should every police officer in the
united states wear a body camera
body cam uh
well that's very interesting
let me ask bill to answer that question
go ahead
well generally that's that's a local uh
issue for each
police force in each community the
political leaders of the community to
decide upon
but i think most law enforcement people
i know
who were originally skeptical of body
cameras
are now coming around to feeling that
they actually are a net benefit
it's a very tough you know it's a very
the whole thing with a body cam
you read it and you read two sides of
the story how do you feel about it
daniel i believe that body cameras would
be very helpful
you think they're good i believe they
show both sides where right now
officers would be vindicated for some of
the things that they've been accused of
and certainly if there were
inappropriate actions those would be
captured but you overall
i support them how about you we're good
with it it's already been put into the
budget for 2021
and uh okay so you'll be having them
we'll be having them okay good
they like them the problem of
police violence has been described as
just the problem of a few bad apples
repeatedly
you're gonna have to speak up please
yeah uh the problem of police violence
has been described by you including
president uh
as just bad apples few bad apples or
people who choke occasionally
um some african-american community
leaders and a lot of others actually
have said it's systemic where do you
stand on that
i don't believe that i don't believe
that i think the police do an incredible
job
and i think you do have some bad apples
i think you'd agree every once in a
while you'll see something
and you do have the other situation too
where they're
under this tremendous pressure and they
they don't handle it well
they call it choking and it happens
and uh no but i don't believe that at
all i think they're
i've met so many police i have the
endorsement of
like so many maybe everybody
and frankly i think they're incredible
people they want to do the right thing
it's a tough job it's a tough job it's a
dangerous job
but i have to say this to the police the
the people of our country love you
you don't hear that you don't hear it
from them but the people of our country
love you and they respect you and they
and you know it you feel it in your
heart or you wouldn't be doing it
or you wouldn't be doing it but there's
a great love and when they see what goes
on and when they see a case like this
where
it solves so quickly they respect the
police a lot
really a lot so you should hear it at
least
we're focusing on violent uh actions but
there have been
countless non-violent protests here in
wisconsin and across the country this
summer
uh people calling for an end to systemic
racism do you believe systemic racism is
a problem in this country
well you know you just keep getting back
to the opposite subject we should talk
about the kind of violence that we've
seen in
portland and here and other places it's
tremendous violence you always get to
the other
side well what do you think about this
or that the fact is that
we've seen tremendous violence and we
will put it out very very quickly if
given the chance and that's what this is
all about
uh yeah i keep hearing about peaceful
protests i hear it about everything and
then i come into an area like this and i
see
the town is burned down i mean you look
at minneapolis
they should have acted much quicker when
we got the national guard in there it
took
literally a half an hour you saw the
scene they formed
they walked it was over and they haven't
had a problem
of any consequence since their police
weren't allowed to do the job that they
could do they have very good police
department but they weren't
now they want to break it up they want
to end it they don't want to have a
police department they want to not only
defund they want to get rid of it
it's ridiculous so i just say this that
the kind of violence
that i say you may have protesters but
you have some really bad people too you
have anarchists and you have the looters
and you have the writers you have all
types you have agitators
and that's what you should be focusing
on with your question
i keep hearing about peaceful protest
it's become
really i think it's hurt the media very
badly because you'll have somebody
standing on
one of the networks i won't say which
one but there are more than one
many of them seeing how it's a peaceful
protest and over the shoulder you see
the whole place is burning down
it's become a pretty common
sight so i don't view the peaceful
protests i think peaceful protesting is
fantastic i think it's great
but by and large this is not peaceful
protest when you walk into a
an area and you see buildings that have
burned down
and fortunately here we stopped it early
and so the damage is relatively minimal
but when you look at some of these areas
that they just don't ask for the help
they refuse to allow
us to go in and help them and by the
time you get there the place is
is disintegrated and then they say it
was a peaceful protest it's not a
peaceful protest and you shouldn't call
it a peaceful protest
okay one more place
my question
the peaceful protests that have happened
you've acknowledged some of them
are peaceful they're calling for
structural change mr blake was shot
i mean seven times in the back do you
believe that there is a need
for structural change what is your
message well i think people are calling
for structural change and then you could
take the people of kenosha
that aren't here and that you won't see
and that aren't protesting but they want
change also they want to see law and
order that's the change they want they
want law and order
they want the police to be police they
want the police to do what they do
better than anybody else in the world
and that's what they want too
you don't see them marching and you
don't see them on the streets
but what they want is they want great
police force they want
people that are going to keep them safe
where
their houses aren't broken into where
they're not
raped and murdered that's what they want
and they're protesters too but they
don't walk down the street up and down
the street
so uh you know just the way it is
just the way it is so i want to thank
you all and i'll see you back at the
plane thank you very much
thank you thank you great job
fantastic job thank you everybody thank
you very much appreciate it